Hey. Hey.
[Silence]
Continuing in Al-Wajeez
in the chapter regarding Adab al-Khala,
the
etiquettes of relieving oneself.
We have mentioned previously
the
things that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam taught us to say when we
enter
the restroom, when we leave.
And that a person begins with his left
foot when entering.
One of the things that we mentioned
yesterday
was that
when a person
is to relieve himself,
the sunnah is to go to a place or be in
a place where
a person completely is
concealed. Their whole body, not just
there private parts.
Of course, concealing the private parts
in
public
is obligatory, wajib.
And revealing private parts
in
public is haram, positively haram.
The Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us in Sahih Muslim
No man is to look at the private parts
of another man, nor any woman
at those of another woman.
However,
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would not just conceal his private
parts, but conceal his entire body
when he would go to relieve himself.
And this is
for
the purpose of
preserving
an individual's dignity.
When you
meet
another human being,
you are essentially
largely
writing into that person's mind
an image of yourself. You're making a
copy of yourself in that person's mind.
Whatever would be added to that copy or
taken away from that copy
is largely hinged on what a person says,
what a person does.
And so,
preserving a person's dignity in public,
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
teaches us
to
keep these kinds of private
private things that
belongs in our home, belongs behind
closed doors.
And privacy
is
something that has levels.
So, the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam didn't treat all of his
companions the same.
There were some that were
you know, more or less acquaintances.
Meaning that they would see him from a
distance, they wouldn't interact with
him that much. He had a a closer circle,
he had a very close circle. And privacy
would be different
in each of those levels.
Privacy would be different in each of
those levels.
To the point where his closest
companions
[Arabic recitation]
to anything that
wouldn't be entirely private.
And we have privacy between
a spouse
between spouses,
right?
Between a husband and wife.
And then there's a level of privacy that
no one is privy to.
Just the person on his own, no matter
who it is.
These are things that are never made
public, not even shared with a person's
own spouse or children or parents,
right?
And one of the things
in that
realm
is a person relieving himself.
This is something that is
very private.
and there may be others as well, such as
a person grooming himself, such as
you know, certain things that a person
does.
Those things belong behind closed doors
and a person is never to
you know,
show any other human being these
parts or this aspect.
And understanding this is very
important.
When you read the books of Tafsir
especially the books of Tafsir that rely
on
you know, that are written
before the year 600 or 700.
So, the earlier books of Tafsir and the
books of Tafsir that are hinged
and based
largely on narration.
We have to understand that the
companions, the Tabi'in, Tabi'
al-Tabi'in, the earlier scholars, the
ancient scholars, they
were individuals of very few words, but
their words had a lot of meanings and
any derivative that you could make of
those words is correct because their
words were balanced.
And when you read in these books,
sometimes you will see something that
will
strike you as
odd.
You will think to yourself,
"Why is this such a big deal?
Why did they understand the verse to
mean this?"
But there is a lot of meaning in that
and a lot of wisdom. This ties into what
we're speaking about.
So, for instance,
one of the things that we see is that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala taught tells
us in the Quran
with respect to the people of Lut,
the people of Shu'aib, the people of
Saleh, the people of Hud, these
damned
civilizations,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
one of the things that was of their
traits was what they do in public
gatherings.
And in your
public gatherings,
you do
that which is
evil and repulsive.
Now, when we say evil and repulsive,
what comes into mind? You think the
worst things, right?
Then you look at
what the companions radiya'llahu anhum
comment on this verse,
that one of the things they were guilty
of is that in their public gatherings,
they would do what is evil and
repulsive.
The companions tell us,
canu
yudarratuna
fil majlis.
They used to pass gas in front of each
other in the gathering.
You think to yourself, the explanation
or the understanding that the companions
have
of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala saying that
these people were destroyed
because of their wickedness
because they used to
do that which is evil and repulsive in
their gatherings.
The companions comment and say evil and
repulsive such as
breaking wind
in publicly.
You think how does that qualify as evil
and repulsive?
This
is not the epitome of evil and
repulsive. The companion understands
that the listener and the reader
understands evil and repulsive.
Immediately, you understand what that
is.
But there are elements of evil and
repulsive that have symptoms.
One of those symptoms is the absence of
shame.
There's no more shame. There's no more
discretion. There's no more dignity.
There's no more honor
in their behavior.
Everything is a joke. Everything's
funny. Everything's entertainment.
Nothing is sacred. Nothing is holy.
And their Nadi, the Nadi in the Arabic
language, is the place where the
chieftains gather in order to
make the most important decrees on
behalf of their nation.
So at the the at the epitome
[Arabic recitation]
of their
you know, the cream of the crop, the
best of them, those in charge who are
making decisions on behalf of their
followers
in their most important gatherings, what
are they doing? Breaking wind in front
of each other.
Joking and laughing.
This isn't about
a person passing gas or this is about a
lack of shame.
Allah is teaching us that these people
had
lost all semblance of shame
even in the most sacred of places.
And so
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
teaches us and iterated and reiterated
and drove home the importance
of
there being a high level of shame,
dignity, and honor
amongst the Muslimin.
Even if a Even if a man is
the poorest of all, even if some of the
companions didn't have
They were so poor
that the women
in the masjid were explicitly commanded
by the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, do not raise your heads from
sujud until the men are completely
standing.
Why did he say this to them?
Huh?
Yeah, but I mean like
because they didn't have enough to cover
themselves.
Because if a woman there in the behind
the men, if they would raise their head
before the men were completely standing,
they would see
the aura because they are so poor,
they're literally wearing rags. This is
all they have. Yet, in spite of that
level of poverty,
they are the most dignified.
The most dignified.
This is what the prophet
taught us. So, for this reason, when he
would relieve himself,
when the companions would relieve
themselves, they would completely
hide their silhouette
and their entire body from any
onlookers, even from their own spouses.
Right?
Even from their own spouses.
And so, the prophet
commanded that when we
relieve ourselves,
that number one,
we conceal our entire body, preferably,
and number two,
that we only expose ourselves
when we are near the place where we are
going to relieve ourselves. So, the
prophet
would perhaps choose a place to relieve
himself.
He would only lift his clothing
when he was close to the ground and
ready to relieve himself.
The most dignified.
If you really want to see an image of
dignity, you want to see an image of a
human being in his most
dignified,
in his most
excellent form in all ways, you read
the descriptions of the prophet
and his companions.
Even though they didn't have
food,
they didn't have clothing, they went
through times where they didn't have
clothing, they didn't have food, they
didn't have they were afraid, they were
in a state of of
dis- displacement.
Yet, in spite of that, you see the
dignity
of men who
might as well have owned the earth and
all that is in it.
This kind of dignity and hayba and
integrity,
this is something that can't be bought,
it can't be purchased. This is something
that a person can only get
from the Quoran.
A person may stumble upon aspects of
this kind of dignity,
but it can only be had in its entirety
from the teachings of the Quoran and the
Sunnah.
[Silence]
Why do you just sit there and stare?
You never knew that that's like
impolite?
Your whole life, you never knew that
it's impolite to invade people's
someone's space by staring at them
nonstop for minutes and minutes on end.
You never knew that.
Your whole life, living in society,
you go around staring at people,
You know, intense.
[Arabic recitation]